that's not the plan
okay so when you hear like okay is this
is this obviously you guys have genuine
love for each other she's your your day
one you guys have two children together
right but uh how much of this also is
business
because you're putting music out there
yeah
oh
um
it's all it's it's all business mixed
with love I think that I'm like a good
listener yeah like like
like I'm a good listener like as far as
like when it comes to that side like he
couldn't tell me how to like change
diaper or something like that you're not
just stay in your lane but like as far
as this I'm like kind of like I want you
to teach me like I genuinely want to
know like I don't you know I don't know
how to move properly as far as stuff
like that like I I will listen and I'll
be like okay you know because actually
I'm gonna tell a story about you okay
okay so so he got locked up the day of
my music video oh so so the day yeah he
was supposed to go to court meet me at
my music video and I was supposed to be
in the video yeah so
um so
when that when he called me was like I'm
not gonna make it just make it lit do
what you got to do and I'm just kind of
like now you got to figure it out so
well that I've never I've never done a
music video I don't even know if I've I
don't even know if I've ever been to one
of his music videos from like to even
like watch see how it's supposed to be
done right like or how he talks to
people or moves
yeah but it was just me you and the
camera guy it wasn't kind of like it
wasn't a really like a production with
like several people and like girls like
and just like having to coordinate like
you know what I mean like so I just kind
of was like oh [__] but I felt like
I really didn't have a choice like make
it lit okay say less I'll make it lit so
then I showed up we actually I couldn't
even get to the house yet until I had to
message the people get into the house
because they didn't know what the [__]
was going on he wasn't answering the
phone it wasn't like I could be like
look this is what happened
I couldn't say that like that would have
looked so bad right so then I just kind
of was like look I just said he was on a
flight he got delayed everybody type
shits yeah so type [__] so it's such an
easy excuse to get out of anything right
they're like [__] it it's okay I can't
make it I got Coke bro like you know so
they they fell for it and I just let
them know like oh I'm gonna make sure
everything's straight so there's like
okay whatever so we go in there I make
sure it's all lit and I don't even know
what the point was but I was just saying
like he wanted me to make a shirt happen
so it happened from jail gave her a
couple appointments yeah so I just kind
of was like okay let me do that and then
um there were certain things that he was
talking to me about prior to shooting
the video like oh we should do this or
we should do that so I made sure to
incorporate that you know so I'm
listening to everything he's saying
whether it's today and if we use it next
week like I'm still listening I wanna I
genuinely want to know right like I want
to learn like I don't know it seems like
you're kind of like a a big part of like
Zeus Network success and I can't imagine
that like their most successful show
being your guys's show they wouldn't
want to continue that if they wanted you
to be like is It season three now or two
if they were like hey
Sean's out of here let's get Jaden in
here and let's run a new season
of
Crazy in Love no I don't think we will
do it I don't think that it should be
yeah I want more music for her I'm just
saying I mean I think that if the bag
might be ready
no no no no I think that anything
shouldn't be you not like we're not
saying no to no money but
we also got a vision you know and we
don't want to give
all right when we Google her name you
want the music to pop up right to say
American rapper I don't want to say
reality's personality model Super Love
and Hip I don't want to say nothing I
want to say rapper so that's because
that's what I mean that's it that's the
business I'm in right
I no I did the only fast thing and uh
great but that's still under my control
I think you're more than like music I
think you're like what I'm saying that's
where my expertise is at but I think
you're awesome yeah like you've mastered
the internet bro like yeah yeah like for
music for music and client reasons
though so it's like music incline but
also just I just think people are
interested in you now man
it's like you just being a rapper me
personally yeah me personally you're a
figure man like people just like what's
going on my son's Maddie I told him why
he's nine I totally my son literally
said you're gonna go interview blueface
tell him I'm mad at him I said why he's
like he broke her Sean's heart I said
what the [__] he's nine years old I
totally agree I totally agree but for me
passing something to somebody it's got
to be music because that's like my
expertise you know I think you have a
lot of other expertise
you wear a lot of different hats bro I
blew up in a year like you blew up quick
off pure strictly my musically inclined
I made everything about music in Arizona
is the first time you brought the mop
out on stage bro my boy reposted he's
like this was the first I'm like I'm
just gonna that seems like it was six
months ago but it was like four or five
years ago no I'm better with Artistry
bro Music is More on my Lane like of
course I can do anything now because I
succeeded at music but I took the music
to to get anywhere you feel me okay so
me doing that with her that's what I
want to put I don't want to push
anything else